me gustaría empezar diciendo que nos han
hecho creer que el ser humano por
defecto es un lobo solitario egoísta por
naturaleza que solo busca sus propios
sus propios intereses pero fijaros cada
vez más la neurociencia presenta muchas
más evidencias de que esto no es cierto
a mí me gusta pensar en el ser humano
como un ser solidario un ser generoso y
poderoso a la vez que busca su propósito
en la vida y que quiere aportar valor a
la sociedad
por eso creo firmemente en un mundo más
humano un mundo que empodere al
individuo
y pueda que utilice toda esta nueva
tecnología para resolver los problemas
de la humanidad
me gustaría empezar compartiendo un poco
de mi experiencia personal
yo estudié informática en la universidad
yo estuve más de 19 años trabajando en
operadoras de telecomunicaciones y en
empresas de tecnología en un momento
dado me di cuenta que aunque me gustaba
lo que hacía no me apasionaba
tardé cuatro años en cambiar de área
profesional y en construir lo que soy
ahora y digo soy porque ahora sí que me
siento plenamente identificada con lo
que hago ahora me gusta mucho mi trabajo
me apasiona y de sentir pasión por lo
que haces es lo que me gustaría
transmitiros a lo largo de esta charla y
sobre todo poniendo foco en cómo
funciona el cerebro
en qué momento estamos
estamos fijaros inmersos en una
revolución tecnológica exponencial se
dice que los próximos 20 años va haber
más cambios que los 300 años anteriores
se dice que los próximos cinco años va a
estar el ser humano conviviendo con las
máquinas fijaos hemos pasado de estar
tecleando en el ordenador conectados a
un cable a estar totalmente obsesionados
con el móvil y lo siguiente va a ser dar
órdenes de voz
se dice que las próximas generaciones no
van a saber lo que es estar desconectado
de la red
estamos en una sociedad hiperconectada
digitalizada donde las empresas van a
basar su competitividad en el uso eficaz
de toda esta tecnología y en la
capacidad de transformarse digitalmente
las organizaciones esta transformación
digital nos está obligando a estar
continuamente aprendiendo y
continuamente cuestionando nos como
estamos haciendo las cosas
entonces lo primero que tendríamos que
empezar a hacer es pensar cómo veo yo
todo este futuro cómo puedo poner en
valor todo lo que soy todo lo que he
aprendido hasta ahora toda mi
experiencia de cara al futuro que viene
y por dónde empezamos a mí me gustaría
proponer un plan de entrenamiento para
prepararnos para la transformación
digital
este plan de entrenamiento tiene cuatro
etapas la primera etapa ponte en forma
donde a correr fijaros yo cuando decidí
que quería cambiar y quería cambiar
muchísimas cosas no sé si porque estaba
asustada o tenía miedo me puse a correr
me puse a correr ya correr y
verdaderamente como en el primer año
corrí mi primer maratón luego siguieron
otras tres más fijaos luego más adelante
aprendí con la neurociencia que el
ejercicio físico es tan importante para
el cerebro como lo es para el cuerpo y
el corazón fijaos el ejercicio físico
mejora nuestras capacidades mentales
nuestras capacidades de memoria nuestra
capacidad de atención genera nuevos
nuevas neuronas en el hipocampo en
nuestro centro de memoria fijaros
también aumenta los niveles de tres
hormonas que son muy importantes para el
cerebro
la primera la dopamina la dopamina la
hormona de la pasión del entusiasmo la
serotonina la hormona del bienestar de
sentirse bien y la oxitocina la hormona
de la confianza
haciendo un ejercicio liberamos
muchísimas endorfinas las endorfinas lo
que nos hacen es reducir nuestro nivel
de estrés
fijaos haciendo ejercicio también
reducimos el riesgo que podemos tener de
tener demencia o de enfermedades como el
alzheimer y ahora os voy a decir algo
que va a ser contundente
el ejercicio físico mueve más neuronas
en el cerebro que cualquier otra
actividad
segunda etapa
aprender un poquito más acerca de cómo
funciona el cerebro y para aquí para
esto me gustaría haceros una pregunta a
ver cuántos de vosotros habéis pensado
en vuestro cuerpo en el último mes
levantar la mano
las navidades y cuántos de vosotros
habéis pensado en vuestro cerebro el
último mes vamos
oye pues no está mal está mal fijaos
normalmente no pensamos en nuestro
cerebro y nuestro cerebro está
involucrado en todo lo que hacemos cómo
pensamos cómo nos sentimos cómo amamos
cómo nos relacionamos
a mí me gustaría contaros dos cosas dos
cosas acerca del cerebro que a lo mejor
los empieza os hace ver el futuro lleno
de posibilidades
la primera el cerebro cambia físicamente
con la experiencia es lo que se llama
neuroplasticidad y esto es una buena
noticia por fin nos podemos olvidar del
cociente intelectual os acordáis eso de
que de por vida te decía si eras más
listo o menos listo si estabas por
encima de la media por debajo de la
media de la clase
todo el mundo puede cambiar nuestro
cerebro está continuamente modelando sé
tanto consciente como inconscientemente
nosotros podemos decidir modelar nuestro
cerebro conscientemente
nuevos aprendizajes nuevas experiencias
lo que hacen es generar nuevos circuitos
neuronales en nuestro cerebro
pero tengo una mala noticia
nuestro cerebro por defecto es muy vago
no le gusta no le gusta la incertidumbre
entonces siempre que puede tira de
patrones y creencias conocidas se dice
que el 90 por ciento de nuestro
conocimiento de nuestro comportamiento
es automático
y cómo podemos romper esta inercia que
tiene nuestro cerebro de actuar de forma
automática
de dos maneras la primera es con
consciencia consciencia para que para
cuestionarme cómo está reaccionando mi
cerebro y a partir de ahí elegir cómo
quiero que acepto cómo quiero que mi
cerebro lo haga la próxima vez y la
segunda es con voluntad voluntad para
que para ir incorporando nuevos hábitos
y nuevos aprendizajes que al final se
traducirán en nuevos circuitos
neuronales
la segunda cosa que quería compartir con
vosotros es que nuestro cerebro es un
órgano profundamente social necesita
interacciones sociales para sobrevivir
naomi es inverter de la universidad de
los ángeles una experta en neurociencia
social quiso investigar qué es lo que
pasaba en el cerebro cuando tenemos
rechazo social
pues bien comprobó que cuando nosotros
sentimos rechazo social se activa la
misma parte del cerebro que cuando
tenemos dolor físico
esto pues nos puede llevar a
cuestionarnos la pirámide de maslow que
si os acordáis decía que las primeras
necesidades las necesidades más básicas
del ser humano son las necesidades
físicas y las necesidades y la ira ni la
seguridad y por encima estaban las
necesidades sociales pues bien desde el
punto de vista del cerebro las
necesidades sociales están al mismo
nivel que las necesidades físicas
eso qué quiere decir que a lo mejor
fijaros con esto podemos pensar que
nuestro cerebro está biológicamente muy
bien preparado para la colaboración
también podemos pensar lo importante que
es para nuestro cerebro desarrollar las
relaciones sociales y generar nuevos
vínculos emocionales con los demás
la tercera la tercera etapa
tenemos que asumir que tenemos tienes
que asumir toda la responsabilidad de
construir el futuro que vosotros queráis
vosotros tenéis que ser los vuestros
propios líderes fijaros cada uno de
nosotros tiene que decidir sea cual sea
el papel que le ha tocado vivir tiene
que decidir si ser uno más
o marcar la diferencia
y marcar la diferencia es crear tu
propia marca personal hay que empezar a
cuestionarse quién soy yo y es lo que me
gusta y es lo que me apasiona
es lo que me apasiona fijaros se me ha
ido el santo el cielo
bueno pues sigo vale en todas y ya está
perdón ya está ya está ya está ya está
por dios
y hay que empezar a decir sé qué es lo
que me apasiona y sobre todo cómo me
cuento yo mi historia porque según como
me cuente mi historia voy a ver una cosa
u otra si yo quiero si lo empiezo yo veo
mi mundo gris lo veré gris
en cambio si yo que yo veo mi mundo
lleno de posibilidades el cerebro me va
a mostrar un mundo lleno de
posibilidades
porque el cerebro te muestra aquello que
tú quieras ver
fijaos me gusta mucho una frase que dice
benjamín disraelí piensa en grande no
vas a llegar más allá de tus
pensamientos
y cómo podríamos ser un líder un líder
que inspire fijaros cómo son cómo son
los líderes que inspiran los líderes que
inspiran cuentan historias se conecta se
conectan con los demás a través de esas
historias son apasionados son
apasionados con su vida apasionados con
lo que hacen con lo que trabajan se
creen que están que tienen el mejor
equipo aunque no lo sea
son auténticos conocen sus fortalezas y
sus debilidades son coherentes con sus
valores
los veedores que inspiran influyen
dedican tiempo a los demás
escuchan
se comprometen consigo mismo y con los
demás
los líderes que inspiran en el universo
les favorece
tercera etapa
aprende a meditar la meditación que va a
hacer desarrollar tu capacidad de
resiliencia la resiliencia la capacidad
de enfrentarse a las adversidades
se dice que las personas que son
resilientes experimentan la vida de una
forma mucho más positiva
y cómo podemos tener una actitud mucho
más positiva ante la vida
richard davie son un neurocientífico de
la universidad de wisconsin prometió
hace muchos años al dalai lama que iba a
investigar cuáles son los efectos de la
meditación
en el cerebro incluso que iba a
investigar los efectos de las emociones
positivas de la compasión y el bienestar
pues bien lo que comprobó es que el
entrenamiento mental
puede cambiar los patrones de actividad
del cerebro
cuando meditamos se activa una parte del
cerebro que es la corteza prefrontal
izquierda es la podéis tocar
esta parte la corteza prefrontal de
izquierda es la que se activa cuando
tenemos pensamientos positivos cuando
estamos sonrientes y cuando en esta es
la parte y se activa cuando meditamos de
la misma manera reduce la activación de
la corteza prefrontal derecha que es la
parte aquí está se activa cuando tenemos
pensamientos positivos pensamientos
negativos perdón y cuando estamos un
poco deprimidos la meditación lo que
hace también es reducir el nivel de
activación de la amígdala y entonces lo
que te permite es modular tus reacciones
emocionales
la meditación también y mejora tu
capacidad y de
de atención fijaos richard de visión
también nos ha dicho nos dice que el
bienestar el sentirse bien es algo que
podemos trabajar y para trabajarlo
podemos podemos trabajar cuatro áreas
las cuatro áreas son la resiliencia el
pensamiento positivo la atención y la
generosidad
la generosidad hacer cosas por los demás
activa el nivel de dopamina en el
cerebro
y por último qué es esto de neuro
liderazgo como que aporta el negro
liderazgo a la transformación digital
fijaos en los últimos en los últimos 15
años no ha habido los modelos de
liderazgo prácticamente no no han
cambiado en cambio hay más de 50 mil
científicos investigando cómo funciona
el cerebro no tendría no tendría sentido
no poder aplicar todo este conocimiento
al mundo de las organizaciones
conocer cómo funciona tu cerebro te va a
permitir poder desarrollar todas estas
habilidades que están siendo que te
demandan tanto en el siglo 21 como por
ejemplo la creatividad y la innovación
el neuro liderazgo es aplicar los
avances de la neurociencia al mundo de
las organizaciones
el neuro liderazgo te puede te puede
ayudar a preparar para la transformación
digital en la medida en que empodera al
individuo le da las posibilidades de
poner su cerebro en las mejores
condiciones para desempeñar cualquier
tarea
apuesta por un líder saludable un líder
que tiene balanceado su cerebro y que
desarrolla nuevos hábitos asociados a la
salud física mental y emocional
el neuro liderazgo construye culturas
colaborativas culturas donde las
personas intercambian ideas donde se
conecta el talento de la organización
donde es donde se puede desarrollar la
creatividad
y por último da la bienvenida a la
diversidad como la mejor manera de ver
nuevas perspectivas y la mejor manera de
poder desde de poder estar mejor
preparados para este mundo tan cambiante
hoy más que nunca se necesitan neuro
líderes que potencien su cerebro para
inspirar a los demás para crear con el
cliente para crear espacios de
colaboración donde se pueda desarrollar
la inteligencia colectiva de la
organización
y me gustaría acabar con una frase que
creo que resume mucho todo lo que he
querido decir hasta ahora
cambia tu cerebro y cambiará tu vida
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]